In Season 2 of Chucky, there is a scene where
the kids gather materials that might help them
reprogram Chucky’s brain, and if you look
closely, one of these materials is a tape
that once belonged to Eddie Caputo, a boy
who attended this very same boarding house
years ago and later went on to become Chucky’s
getaway driver, as seen in the original movie.
Not only is this a fun easter egg, but it also
establishes the idea that Charles and Eddie may
have items tucked away in hidden places throughout
the school, an idea that comes back in a huge way
at the end of this season. To learn about all
the easter eggs, references, hidden secrets,
glaring mistakes and everything you might have
missed, stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Hello Fresh
(metal intro)
Welcome to Things You Missed.
(melancholic piano music)
OK, if you watch my videos, you may
remember how relieved I was when I
was finally done covering Bride and Seed. I
only did it so that my Chucky series could
be considered complete and we could move
onto the serious stuff. Then, in Season 1,
the main focus was how that season was a
tribute to Child’s Play 2, which creator
Don Mancini explained was because so many fans
consider Child’s Play 2 to be their favorite.
My hope was that Season 2 would take the next
logical step and honor Child’s Play 3. Afterall,
like Child’s Play 3, it was going to
take place at a boarding school. And
it would feature a small militia
of Chucky dolls opposing Andy,
the inverse of Child’s Play 3 which features
a small militia of kids opposing Chucky.
However, as I watched Season 2, I came to
a horrifying realization. This wasn’t an
homage to the third movie… it was an homage to
the fifth one. Seed of Chucky. (horror sting)
As a result, Chucky Season 2 throws horror out the
window, pun intended, and it’s all about comedy,
gross out moments, celebrity cameos, meta-horror
references and way too much petty bickering.
I’ve got to commend Mancini for having
the balls to do this. I’m sure he knows
how fans feel about Seed, and yet he stuck
to his guns and gave us more of it. Four
times more. Regardless of my feelings
towards this season, I still feel like
it contains some interesting things you
may have missed. So let’s get into them.
(rock music)
The season picks up right where
the previous one left off,
with Andy hijacking the truck full of Chuck in
order to try and destroy them. It’s here that
we meet the doll that would later become known
as The Colonel. He gets into it with two others,
and I have a fan theory about who
one of them is. Listen to this line.
– [The Colonel] They also say
it ain’t the size that counts.
So I wouldn’t worry about those
pathetic stick arms of yours.
– My theory is that this insult
inspired this Chucky to take steroids,
resulting in the creation of one of
this season’s antagonists: Buff Chucky.
As soon as I saw Andy drive the truck
over the ledge, I was screaming,
“he didn’t get out of the cockodoodie truck!” Come
to find out, he actually didn’t for some reason,
he just somehow miraculously survived the
crash, which happens right at the foot of
this giant cross, perhaps foreshadowing
the religious setting for this season.
Season 2 Episode 1 is titled “Halloween II”,
because it’s the second CHUCKY episode
that takes place on Halloween. However,
there is a double meaning here, because there
are going to be similarities to the 1981 movie:
Halloween II. The jack o’lanterns in the intro
have Chucky’s face carved into them in the same
style as the skull on the poster for Halloween
II. During the episode we see that Jake carved one
of Chucky-lanterns himself. I… don’t know why he
would traumatize himself like that. But he does.
As I mentioned in my video on Season 1,
Dr. Mixter is named after a character
from Halloween II. So these references
may be our clue that Dr. Mixter is going
to play a bigger role this season. A
role that would make her align more
with a different doctor from the Halloween
franchise: Dr. Sartain, the psychiatrist of
a serial killer who becomes so invested in
his patient, that he becomes evil himself.
But from Bride of Chucky onwards, I’m
pretty sure all of my Chucky analysys
have made mention of the horror movie
franchise that Chucky takes on the most:
The Scream franchise. This season may be the
most blatant Scream emulation of all. It starts
with Jake receiving a cell phone call from
Chucky, doing his best Ghostface impression.
– [Jake] Hello?
– [Chucky] Is Tamara home?
– Who?
– Tamara?
– This is actually kind of a hybrid
easter egg. The phone call and
voice resemble the beginning of Scream,
but the line is actually the line from
the beginning of The Strangers, when one of
the titular strangers shows up at the door.
– Is Tamara here?
– No, you’ve got the wrong house.
– The rest of the phone call plays out like a
typical Scream opening, with Chucky asking
him questions such as why he’s home alone,
revealing familiarity with Jake by asking
about his significant other, then frightening
Jake by proving that real danger is afoot.
The doorbell rings, but no one is out front, and
Jake grabs a knife. It’s all just like Scream.
At first, he thinks it’s a classmate named
Ellis, which may be a reference to Major Elllis,
the bully character from Child’s
Play 3. We’ve seen this move before.
– [Chucky] This isn’t Ellis…
– [Ghostface] I’m not Randy.
– The Screaminess continues later in
the episode when Devon recognizes
Caroline's new doll from something.
– [Devon] She looks a little
like the Bride of Chucky.
Remember that movie?
– [Jake] Yeah, with Jennifer Tilly.
– We do know that there are movies about Chucky
already, because part of Seed took place on
the set of a movie called Chucky Goes Psycho.
However, this is the first time we’re hearing
that the actual Chucky movies in our world,
may also exist in their world, which is a
concept that originated in the Scream franchise,
which contains the in-universe Stab franchise.
In addition to Chucky Goes Psycho and Bride of
Chucky, it seems Seed of Chucky also exists in
some form in the Chucky universe, because you can
spot a poster for it in Jennifer Tilly’s house.
The show continues to lean
heavily on Scream throughout
the season. Nica borrows a line from Casey Becker…
– Listen ***hole!
– [Ghostface] No you!
– [Zac] The rest of these will contain spoilers for
Scream, so just skip to the next chapter if
you haven’t seen them. In Episode 3, we learn
that there are two Chucky’s operating at
the school, just as there are always two
Ghostface killers in every Scream movie.
In Episode 8, Glenda kills
someone with a defibrillator…
– Hey Mom? Clear.
(electricity) (screaming)
– … very much like in Scream 4…
– Can I just have one final word?
– What? Please?
– No.
Clear.
– Clear?
– [Sidney] Clear!
– Note, that one might actually be more of a
reference to the first Child’s Play, where
Chucky kills Dr. Ardmore with some kind of other
shock device at the hospital. But like Scream,
the Chucky franchise goes to New York City,
which is possibly a really big coincidence.
However, the aspect of Scream that is most
borrowed by Chucky is the fact that the characters
are self aware and know about horror movies. The
season is littered with parodies and homages,
so I’m gonna talk about most of them,
and uncover even more Things You Missed.
(impact)
I had been using HelloFresh on my own for about
a year before they ever reached out to sponsor
a video. Each meal comes with a recipe page,
so at the beginning I decided to save some of
the recipes I really liked. This is it. As you
can tell, it's basically every single recipe.
HelloFresh is the essential meal kit delivery
service. Everything you need to cook delicious,
chef-crafted recipes is delivered to your doorstep
so you can spend more time
doing the things you love.
You’ll only find quality ingredients
in HelloFresh’s recipes. In fact,
ingredients travel from the farm to your home
in less than 7 days, so you know they’re fresh.
I love how you get the perfect amount
of ingredients to make your meal. No
more going to the grocery store
to get cilantro for a recipe,
but they only sell way more than you need and
75% of it goes bad in the fridge later that week.
NO MORE.
Each week you can choose what you want from over
40 weekly dishes, but you don't have to. If I'm
too busy, I'll let it choose for me, and I've
honestly discovered some of my favorites that way.
It's healthy, it uses sustainable, recycle
friendly materials, and it saves money,
so it really checks all the boxes for me.
I've been telling everybody in my life
about HelloFresh for the past year,
and they always ask me if I'm sponsored,
and I say no, it's just been a life changer
for me. I guess I won't be able to say that
anymore, but with this amazing deal, you can.
Just go to HelloFresh dot com and use code
CZsWorld65 for 65% off plus free shipping!
That's code CZsWorld65 at hellofresh.com to
get 65% off, and then brag about it to all of your friends.
(ominous music)
In the Halloween episode, we see an angel and a
devil trick-or-treating together, which I see as
a foreshadowing of the good and evil metaphor that
comes up so often during this season. We already
know about Nica and Chucky, a good character and
an evil character being forced to share one body.
Something similar appears to happen after Jake
and Devon capture a Chucky scout and attempt to
reprogram his brain. Chucky pretends that he’s
torn between “good Chucky” and “bad Chucky”.
Due to the religious setting, Chucky is constantly
portrayed as The Devil, and they even perform an
exorcism on him at the end. When Jake and Devon
first show up to Lexy’s house, she’s listening
to the song “Devil I Know” by Allie X, and this
also foreshadows the exorcism of Chucky. Contrary
to that, newcomer Nadine is the angel. Chucky
takes her out by stating that fairies love to
fly before throwing her out a window, but she
comes back to speak to Lexy in the form of an
angel… which is actually just a suit with lights,
but I’m not here to talk about the costume budget.
In addition to the contrast shown between
good and evil, the show also explores the gray
area in between the two, with many good characters
expressing feelings of guilt. We get to see how
each of them deals with guilt differently.
The first is actually Lexy’s mom, Mrs. Cross.
– For everyone who lost somebody in last year's
tragic events, I know exactly what they're going
through because I'm going through it too. The
grief. The anger. The guilt. The survivors' guilt.
– It’s not known how much she really struggles with
guilt, considering most of what she does is faked
for social media, but we see survivors’ guilt
manifest much more convincingly in Jake. During
an art history class about the seven deadly sins,
he asks his teacher if there are some sins that
are unforgivable, still shaken by the fact that
his innocent foster brother lost his life due to
Jake’s connection with Chucky.
In a later class,
that teacher senses the guilt eating at him.
– You think I’m overcome with guilt?
–I think something’s eating away at you.
– And sure enough, Jake’s guilt
ties back into the main plot,
it’s the reason that he wants
to keep Scout Chucky alive.
– I need to try and do it a different
way. All I feel is guilt...
If I really want to forgive myself, I
have to be able to forgive him first.
– Nadine has a different relationship with
guilt. She feels guilt over her bad habit
with stealing things, but unlike Jake, she’s a
little too comfortable with letting go of it.
As long as she declares her sins in the
confessional, it all goes away, so she
often ends up with long sessions in the booth,
completely missing the point of why she’s there.
However, this makes her a
perfect companion to Lexy,
who keeps all of her guilt bottled up inside.
Through her final conversation with Angel Nadine,
she’s finally able to share
her feelings with those she loves.
Devon, on the other hand, tries to deal with his
guilt by physically overcoming
it, seeing it as a sickness.
– [Bryce] I thought you were sick. You shouldn’t
be out of bed if that’s the case.
– [Devon] Maybe it’s just something I ate.
– Or maybe the feeling isn’t biological.
Maybe it’s more philosophical. Guilt.
It has a funny way of manifesting in us.
– The point is that each character has
their own way of handling guilt. The
protagonists find a way to handle it, while
the antagonists make no attempt to address it,
which all comes to a head before the
exorcism, where each of them must make
their confessions in order to proceed. It’s
probably the most well written though line
in the season. I wish I could say the same
about how Dr. Mixter’s character was set up.
– [Lexy] Our family therapist can't be in league with
a supernaturally possessed doll, right? RIGHT?
RIGHT?
– By the way, in Lexy’s room, there’a a Blue Öyster
Cult poster, a reference to her singing their
song, “(Don’t Fear) The Reaper” to Caroline
as a lullaby in Season 1. Another Season 1
connection can be seen in this guy, James. He’s
interviewing Mrs. Cross, and he’s actually the
same guy that interviewed her when she was
mayor throughout Season 1. Crazy how no one
in the media is putting together that the Chucky
doll is attached to so many of these tragedies.
After a family therapy sesh, Dr. Mixter gives
Caroline a new doll to help her cope with her fear
of dolls. This is kind of a callback to the 7th
movie, Cult of Chucky, where Tiffany claims that
this Good Guy doll was used to help Alice Pierce
overcome her family’s Chucky related tragedy.
Anyway, when it comes to Caroline’s doll,
Lexy smashes it against the ground to try
to make sure it isn’t alive, and we see
the same camera angle used when Junior
used Chucky as a blunt object to attack
his dad with last season. This could be
a tiny clue that this Wedding Belle
doll is actually Chucky in disguise.
Lexy’s precautions don’t save her
from being targeted by Chucky,
who brings a homemade bomb and detonates
it on Jake’s young foster brother, Gary.
Knowing the truth won’t be believed, they make
up a story about how they built a homemade bomb
which was accidentally detonated. This is
what lands them in the Catholic school. I
get why they don’t want Chucky being alive to
be part of their story, but their cover story
that they made the bomb themselves doesn’t
make them look any better. This is so stupid.
They find themselves being transported to
the Catholic School in a blue school bus,
kind of reminiscent of Andy being shipped
to the military school in Child’s Play 3.
Season 2 Episode 2, “The Sinners Are
Much More Fun” is titled after a lyric
from the Billy Joel song,
“Only the Good Die Young”,
and opens with some franchise easter eggs
in Jennifer / Tiffany’s house. There’s a never
before seen photo from Glen and Glenda’s
5th birthday party in Seed of Chucky,
which sits alongside Jennifer’s most improved
actress award, also from Seed. In that film,
it was used by Tiffany to knock out Redman, and
in this season, Glenda uses it to knock out Glen.
Moving on through the house, Tiffany has a huge
mirror above her bed, and when she wakes up screaming,
it begins to crack. It wouldn’t be the
first time she cracked a ceiling mirror,
because in Bride of Chucky, two of
her kills come as the result of a
champagne bottle hurled at the
mirror above a bed at a motel.
Back at the school, Jake, Devon and
Lexy are sitting in on their first
homily with the headmaster, Father
Bryce, who loves using metaphors.
–On God’s team, every confession is a victory… And
God sure does love a winner.
– [Lexy] I despise sports metaphors.
– She probably dislikes sports metaphors because of
the “Super Bowl of slaughter” speech that Chucky
gave Jake in Season 1, that almost convinced
him to take Lexy out. He’s an instant replay.
– It's the Super Bowl of slaughter.
And you can't just sit in the stands, you know?
We all gotta get out there and get in the game.
Unfortunately for Lexy, there would be an all
out blitz of sports metaphors in Season 2.
– [Bryce] I'm sure you boys are anxious to get on the
straight and narrow, get your lives back on track,
back on the right track, back on the fast track.
– I just love sports metaphors.
– Episode 3 would be titled “Hail Mary!”,
which in addition to religious practice,
is also a play in football, which
is usually used as a last ditch
effort at the end of the game. Not
that I would know, as a Bears fan.
It makes sense though, because brainwashing
Chucky is Jake’s last ditch attempt to give
himself closure about what happened to Gary.
Unfortunately, he’s underestimated his opponent.
– [Chucky] I should know. I’m
like the MVP of serial murder.
– [Zac] He even manages to pull off the upset
in episode 5, against Buff Chucky.
– How did I do, coach?
– And, later on, in preparation
to go up against The Colonel,
Jake works another sports
metaphor into his gameplan.
– You know, whatever battle this Colonel has
brewing, we need to have it on our own terms.
– And what terms would those be?
– Home court advantage.
– All those sports metaphors have got me
gassed, so I’m gonna take a short timeout,
but when I come back, I’m gonna be
dealing even more Things You Missed.
(impact)
(tense music)
Outside of the threat of Chucky,
there is another evil lurking in the halls
of Incarnate Lord, Lexy’s childhood bully,
Trevor. In season 1, Lexy was the bully, so
she tries to channel some of that energy to
push back against Trevor -- effectively
creating a Bully vs Bully scenario.
When I first saw this, I wondered if it
could be foreshadowing of an eventual Chucky
vs Chucky battle of some kind, and it later
came to fruition. But in order to get there,
the 2nd Chucky had to be snuck into the
school, so a Good Guy doll is mailed as
part of Sister Ruth’s Christmas toy drive
-- even though it’s still weeks away.
– [Bryce] That’s wonderful sister
Elizabeth. No time like the present.
– Is that… supposed to be a pun? Cause
present? Like… Christmas present?
The students aren’t supposed to have access
to phones, so the trio has theirs confiscated,
and noted on this document, to keep track of
which phone belongs to whom. Let’s zoom in the
names. One of them is Mauro LaCaprara. This
is the name of a production designer who has
worked on many major TV shows filmed in Toronto,
such as the Handmaid’s Tale and Clarice. Chucky
was also filmed in Toronto. It doesn’t appear
that he worked on it, but many of his jobs went
uncredited, so that could be the case again. I’m
gonna count it as a crew reference easter egg.
And speaking of it being filmed in Toronto,
Lexy has two posters in her room of the small
Toronto based rock back Kingdom of Birds.
As Sister Elizabeth is tagging each of the gifts,
there are a few more crew references. This red tag is labeled:
The Mancini Family after CHUCKY series
creator Don Mancini. The white tag says:
The Colavecchia Family, named after David and John
Colavecchia, who worked in the camera department.
The green tag says The Mrkobrada Family. James
and Steve Mrkobrada also worked camera department.
There’s also a tough to spot easter egg in
Episode 1, when Lexy is rummaging through
her mother’s medicine cabinet, one of the
bottles was prescribed by Dr. Douglas Gabor,
which is a slightly altered version of Gabriella
Douglas, the first assistant art director
There’s not another crew reference easter
egg until episode 7, when Bryce brings out
the Exorcism for Dummies book, which is a play
on the Voodoo for Dummies book introduced in
Bride. Exorcism for Dummies is written by Richard
Darling, a reference to Rick Darling the property
master on both Seasons 1 and 2. It turns out
that Tiffany held onto Voodoo for Dummies,
we see it again in Episode 8. It’s written by
Don Mancini, our last crew reference easter egg.
While not technically a crew reference,
there is a meta-horror moment when Jake
comments that Father Bryce reminds him
of his dad. That’s because Mr. Wheeler,
his brother Logan, and Father Bryce are
all played by the same actor: Devon Sawa.
The first victim this season… other
than Tiffany, and all those Chuckys,
and Gary… is Sister Elizabeth who
has a heart attack upon seeing him.
– Just looking at me is scary
enough to give you a heart attack?
– He shouldn’t be that surprised, because this has
happened before. It’s a reference to the way that
Colonel Cochrane was killed in Child’s Play 3, and
it’s another reason I thought Season 2 was going
to be a tribute to that third movie. But, as you
know, it went in the direction of Seed of Chucky,
carrying on its tradition of bombarding us with
needless pop-culture references. I’m gonna go
through them, but if you’re not interested in
that, feel free to skip to the next chapter.
When Chucky holds them hostage at the beginning,
he mocks their friendship for not spending
time together, and this is Devon’s rebuttal.
– We’ve been busy.
– Well now you’re all gonna get busy dying.
– That might be a reference
to The Shawshank Redemption.
– I guess it comes down to a simple
choice really. Get busy living. Or get busy dying.
– I’m sure you didn’t miss the Scooby Doo reference.
– …and I wouldn’t have gotten away with it
too if it weren’t for you meddling kids.
– After the truck crash, the head of the female
doll somehow ends up in Tiffany’s bed. (screams)
A parody of the horse head scene
from The Godfather. (screams)
Later that day, Tiffany can be seen watching
Liar, Liar, when Nica makes this comment.
– [Nica] I know you went through all
of Jennifer Tilly’s Simpsons money.
– Jennifer Tilly isn’t on the Simpsons, so what’s
the deal with this? Luckily, I happen to know
a Simpson’s expert who can explain it much
better than I can. Here’s The Simpson’s Theory.
– Hey guys! Now I want to start off by saying that although Jennifer
Tilly wasn't a regular cast member of The Simpsons, she was
previously married to late Simpsons co-creator
Sam Simon, and when it came to their divorce in 1993, a
percentage of Simon's payments from Fox was awarded to her.
Then she later appeared as herself
on Season 24’s “Gone Abie Gone”,
where she even references said Simpsons Money.
– I've read every expert on poker,
and watched Jennifer Tilly's DVD.
– Start with your Simpsons
Money. Use the little girl voice,
and take them for everything they've got. Now,
I'm needed on the set of Bride of Chucky V.
– And there you have it folks. That is your random Simpsons fact of the day.
Thans so much for having me on, Zac.
– Thank you Lydia. I’ll put a link to her
channel in the description. Moving along,
when the kids try to reprogram Chucky, they
clip his eyes open using what appears to be
hairclips as a parody of the brainwashing scene
in A Clockwork Orange, where Alex is conditioned
to feel nausea whenever he’s exposed to violence,
which is exactly what happens to Chucky. Instead
of showing him war footage, they show him
horror movies, like The Thing and Psycho II.
In Episode 4, the twins invite some guests over
to celebrate their birthday behind Tiffany’s back.
– We figured you wouldn’t want to have people
over given your Norma Desmond vibes as of late.
– [Zac] Norma Desmond is the forgotten silent movie
star in the 1950 noir film Sunset Blvd,
who, similar to Tiffany, never leaves
her mansion and revels in the past,
watching her own old movies. In Tiffany’s
case, they aren’t actually her movies,
but you get the point. Both characters
are delusional -- and insane.
Not long after, Tiffany apologizes to her
guests for being a recluse over the last year,
and says she’s entering her Garbo era. This
is a reference to another silent film star,
Greta Garbo, who is known for her melancholic
roles. So, essentially nothing like Tiffany
or Jennifer Tilly, which makes it kind
of funny if you know who Greta Garbo is.
Later on, when Buff Chucky
is discovered by Sister Ruth,
who mistakes him for a God, he
makes more of a 90s reference.
– [Chucky] I like your style, Sister Act.
– Sister Ruth.
– Sister Act is a comedy franchise starring
Whoopie Goldberg. Nevermind the fact Chucky
was dead in 1992 when the first one came out,
dead in 1993 when the second one came out,
and was literally just a dismembered arm in
2006 when the broadway musical premiered. The
creators of this show clearly care
a lot more about referencing their
favorite IPs than having their
own show make any logical sense.
It gets really bad shortly after. When I first saw
the bald Chucky known as The Colonel, I thought it
had something to do with the end of Child’s
Play 2 or beginning of Child’s Play 3, where
we see the factory that the Good Guys are made
in, and some of them have not received hair yet.
It wasn’t until this very strange scene
that I ended up looking into the character
and discovered who he’s really supposed
to be… and I have a lot to say about it.
(impact)
(war march music)
The Colonel Chucky is a reference to an
iconic character from a 1979 war movie known
as Apocalypse Now. His name is Colonel Walter
Kurtz, and he is a rogue army officer who went
insane and started commanding his own troops
in Cambodia, kind of like how The Colonel in
Chucky sets up his own camp in the wilderness and
commands his own unit of Good Guy dolls.
After Andy gets the better of him in
Episode 6, The Colonel repeatedly says
“the horror” before passing away, a clear
takeoff of Colonel Kurtz’s final moments
in Apocalypse Now. We’re shown Flashbacks of
the Vietnam war. Charles Lee Ray was never
in the Vietnam war -- it began before
he was born and ended when he was 16.
In my opinion, the mere act of referencing another
property doesn’t make it funny. If you’re doing
it in a way that adds entertainment value, that’s
one thing, but just putting a random war flashback
that doesn’t even fit, just because Francis Ford
Coppola did it, isn’t all that entertaining.
Let’s look at The Simpsons again as an example.
The Simpsons love a good parody episode. Every
year they do Treehouse of Horror. But part of the
fun of watching Treehouse of Horror is learning
how the established characters of Springfield
will change a horror story that we already know.
In the Treehouse of Horror III,
segment “Clown Without Pity”,
Homer buys his son a talking Krusty doll for
his birthday. It’s a parody of Child’s Play,
but they don’t just run through the plot of
the movie, they use the talking murder doll
concept in a way that fits the style
and humor we love in the Simpsons.
– Take this object, but beware,
it carries a terrible curse.
– Ooh, that’s bad.
– But it comes with a free frogurt!
– That’s good!
– The frogurt is also cursed.
– That’s bad.
– But you get your choice of topping.
– That’s good!
– The toppings contain potassium benzoate…
that’s bad.
– Can I go now?
– You don’t have to have seen Child’s Play
to appreciate “Clown Without Pity”. But
if you haven’t seen Apocalypse Now,
good luck understanding what the hell
that Colonel Kurtz reference was. Also
his scene is a total disaster. Roll it.
– Give me liberty,
or give me death… Remember the Alamo!
Auuughhhh!
– [Lexy] Who's Khan?
– What is going on here? Why is Lexy asking “who’s
Khan?” It almost feels like she’s responding to a
line that was cut from the show. Has the editing
really gotten that bad? Here’s my last thing on
this topic. When your media references are just
references for the sake of references, you start
to lose clarity of if they ever are references.
For example, take Tiffany’s line towards Caroline…
– [Tiffany] Clever girl!
– Like, was that supposed to
be a Jurassic Park reference?
– Clever girl!
– Or was she just calling Caroline clever? You
can’t even tell anymore. Anyway, rant over,
let’s get back to where we were.
Episode 2. I mentioned that Tiffany
was watching Jennifer Tilly’s performance
in Liar, Liar, and in that same episode,
Father Bryce makes Jake read
a biblical passage about lies.
– [Jake] When he lies, he speaks according to his own
nature, for he is a liar, and the father of lies.
– It’s very fitting that lies are
such a big focus on this episode,
because Chucky’s lies would have a major
impact. When he acts as if he’s been
changed by the Clockwork Orange treatment,
the characters drop their guard around him,
allowing him to make one of the most
devastating kills of the series.
Moving on to Episode 3, we meet Father O’Malley,
who is clearly tired of Nadine coming in every
week to do confession with him. The character is a
tribute to Reverend William O’Malley, who is known
for his portrayal of Father Dyer in The Exorcist,
where he also served as a technical advisor. Of
all the films that Chucky Season 2 imitates,
the strongest influence, other than Scream, is
probably The Exorcist, but I’ll come back to that
later in this video when I talk about the ending.
During stage 1 of the brainwashing
scene, one of the disturbing clips
they show Chucky is someone falling out
of a window onto a car -- it’s the exact
same as the first kill we ever saw Chucky
make, Aunt Maggie in the original movie.
(slam)
Then during stage 2, he sees Nadine
setting up the phone and says this.
– Aunt Maggie. Chucky wants
to watch the 9 o’clock news.
– This is the exact like said by Andy in
the, shortly after meeting Chucky in the
original. In his dazed state, this was probably
triggered by seeing Nadine, who looks similar to,
and has the same hairstyle as Aunt
Maggie. It’s also foreshadowing,
because he eventually kills Nadine the
same way he killed Aunt Maggie: by throwing her out a window.
She ends up landing on a statue of the
virgin Mary, causing the image to resemble
Michelangelo’s sculpture, Pietà, which depicts
Jesus dying in the arms of Mary. I feel like
this may be connected to Nadine returning as an
angel, but I don’t really know anything about
the Catholic lore. There’s also a shot while
Nadine is doing her “Hail Marys” where she
pats a smaller statue on the head, maybe a small
clue that she’ll be landing on a statue’s head.
After the brainwashing is complete Lexy
is tasked with keeping an eye on Chucky,
and he asks her a variety of annoying
questions, one of which is “do you have
a cat”? This is a callback to season 1 episode 1
where Chucky’s first victim is Jake's cat.
We also see him take out a cat in the 2019 remake.
Episode 4 is a weird one -- it’s called Death
on Denial, a play on Death on the Nile, a
1978 murder mystery film, which is fitting because
this episode is all about a murder mystery party.
There’s a line that caught my attention,
where Glenda mentions having spoken to Tiffany
/ Jennifer’s accountant, Stan. Stan was the name
of Jennifer’s limo driver / secret lover in Seed.
He appeared to have died at the end of that movie,
but then again, so did Jennifer Tilly. However,
when we meet Jennifer Tilly, she appears to
be Tiffany’s accountant? I’m not really sure
what’s going on here, or if we’ll ever find out.
Before the guests arrive, the three can be
seen eating Swedish Meatballs for dinner,
Tiffany’s specialty, and
Chucky’s supposed favorite food.
Speaking of favorite foods, when the
real Jennifer Tilly finally does appear,
she’s got one thing on her mind. Roll it.
–  I’m starving. You promised me chocolate.
– Funny enough, chocolate is
what got her into this mess
in the first place. She only encountered
Tiffany Valentine because she snuck into
a prop room at the movie studio
to secretly snack on chocolate.
If you’re like me, you probably had a
lot of questions about this party that
remain unanswered. Primarily, why is Glen and
Glenda’s birthday being celebrated in November,
when we already know that they were
born in March 2004? I swear they’re
just trying to make the timeline
difficult for me at this point…
But who are these seemingly random party
guests? What is their significance? And why
does this butler look so familiar? I have
all the answers that Liv Morgan didn’t.
(impact)
(girly pop music)
The twins wanted a surprise party, so
they invited some of their mother’s
friends to the house without her knowing
to “surprise” them. This already doesn't
make sense, but it may have been
a strategy to help distract her,
making it easier for Glen and Glenda
to sneak out Nica. So who are these people?
Auntie Gina is introduced first. She isn’t
anyone’s real aunt, I think she’s more of an
honorary aunt for the twins, kind of like
how Aunt Maggie wasn’t Andy’s real Aunt,
she was just a friend of his mother. Her full
name is Gina Gershon, and she co-starred with
Jennifer Tilly in the 1996 thriller, Bound,
where the two shared a lesbian relationship,
which we find out is real in the world
of CHUCKY. In fact, when Gina sneaks up
on her in the bedroom, you can see the Bound
poster in the background at that very moment.
Similarly, Uncle Pants is not Glen and Glenda’s
real uncle, he’s Joe Pantaliano, another actor
friend, who was also in Bound, where he plays
Jennifer Tilly’s boyfriend, Caesar. Apparently,
he too has an ongoing relationship with her, we
literally see him caught with his pants down.
Then there’s Sutton Stracke. I guess Jennifer
and Sutton are just friends in real life. The
final guest is Meg Tilly, the real life sister of
Jennifer Tilly. When I first heard that she was
going to be cast for Season 2, I assumed she would
be playing Tiffany’s sister, who was referenced
in Seed, and as far as we know, still alive. But I
was wrong, she’s just playing herself. Ironically,
Meg actually is Glen and Glenda’s aunt, because
the twins’ biological mother is Jennifer Tilly.
The Butler is the only who isn’t playing
himself, but if he still looks familiar,
it may be because the actor, Tony Nappo,
played Gus Colyard in the Saw franchise.
As if that wasn’t enough star power, the episode
ends with a sit-down between Chucky and WWE star
Liv Morgan, and I just gotta say: what is the
deal lately with these WWE stars being able to
manipulate entertainers for guest spots, seemingly
at will? Between this, the “Alexa Bliss” song by
Bowling for Soup, and the time Dead Meat did
like a whole podcast season of just WWE stars,
I’d like to know who runs their marketing team.
Or maybe you just have to be a WWE fan to get it.
But I guess if Justin Fields randomly wanted
to come on CZsWorld, yeah, I’d probably do it.
There's one more item I’d like to point out in this
episode, but I do need to spoil the movie Psycho
to do it, so spoiler alert until the end of this
chapter. After the butler is found, and everyone
is discussing who the killer could be, the finger
is pointed at Glen and Glenda, to which Glen says:
– We wouldn’t hurt a fly.
– Those who have seen my Seed of Chucky episode
may have picked up on this. In that movie,
Glen and Glenda are a split personality
both trapped inside the body of this doll,
switching back and forth in regards to who is
in control. It’s the same concept as Norman
and Norma Bates in Psycho, and as a result,
there are a ton of Psycho references in Seed.
So this line is also a Psycho
reference. At the end of the movie
we hear Norma’s internal monologue,
and in an attempt to look innocent, she says this.
– They’re probably watching me. Let them
see what kind of a person I am… I’m not
even gonna swat that fly. …and they’ll
say ‘why she wouldn’t even harm a fly’.
– And this idea comes back a couple episodes
later, as Jake, Devon, Lexy and Nadine are
still trying to determine if their reprogrammed
Chucky is really dangerous or not. He literally
kills a fly, foreshadowing that he’s not
the harmless doll that Jake thinks he is.
One more (maybe?) Psycho reference,
when Tiffany slices up Meg Tilly,
the music sounds a lot like the music in Psycho.
(dramatic music)
After awakening from a bad dream,
Glen can be seen reading Great
Expectations. This novel was written
by British author Charles Dickens,
a callback to Glen’s childhood spent in the UK
before ever being reborn as a human. That day,
when Tiffany asks what happened to Nica and
Glenda, I noticed Glen’s eye give a little twitch.
– Tell me where Glenda took Nica.
– This is something that happened in Seed,
Glen’s eye would twitch under stressful
circumstances that are just too much to deal with.
Tiffany’s outfit during this scene
contains these strange playing cards,
probably referencing her career
as a professional poker player,
which I talked about in Season 1. Anyway,
after Glen discovers the real Jen Tilly
trapped in doll form, Tiffany BURNS DOWN
THE HOUSE which feels very unnecessary.
Back at the school, the brainwashed scout
Chucky fights and defeats Buff Chucky,
and in the aftermath Father Bryce
orders Sister Ruth to throw away
the tattered doll. It’s an important
Chucky tradition for someone to try
to trash the antagonistic toy -- this is
the eighth time someone has attempted it.
As we get further into the season
there are more and more callbacks
to the original movie series. For example:
Andy is now being kept prisoner by Chucky, in
a cabin, where he’s tortured. It’s revenge for
when Andy kept Chucky’s head as his prisoner,
in his cabin, and tortured him. Cool detail
about the cabin, if you bring up the lights,
you can see many knives stored overhead,
probably the knives of each of the
Chucky’s that The Colonel has killed.
Sister Ruth is the next to discover that
Chucky is alive, and he tells her that she
should be blonde. He told Tiffany the
same thing when they first met in the
flashback during Season 1, which suggests
that Chucky has a thing for Sister Ruth.
As Kyle, Nica, and Glenda are staying
in a hotel en route to New Jersey,
Kyle has a pack of cigarettes labeled
“Kincaid”. As far as I know, this isn’t
a brand you can still find, so it must be a
reference to Jade Kincaid from Bride of Chucky,
one of the few surviving characters who has yet
to make an appearance in the TV series. Also,
Kyle has a necklace that says “Mom” on it,
which is a strange thing for an orphan to have.
A report comes on the TV, breaking the news
that Jennifer Tilly is now wanted for murder.
The photo that they use is from the 2019
Saturn Awards. The Saturns were briefly
mentioned by Jake and Devon in Season 1. If you’re
curious, the photo used in the 2nd news report,
where Tiffany freaks out about the
terrible picture they used of her,
was taken at the premiere of Panic Room in 2002.
It’s weird that they would use such an old photo,
but it’s a perfect opportunity for me to promote
my Things You Missed episode on Panic Room.
At Lord Incarnate, Father Bryce puts the school
on lockdown, but Lexy and Nadine are able to reach
Jake and Devon’s room anyways, by climbing
out their window and into the boys’ window.
They probably expected us to forget that they
showed the outside of Lexy and Nadine’s room,
and unless they are both Spider-man, they’re
no way the girls pulled this off. The creators
of this show need to stop underestimating me.
I didn’t forget when the twins' birthday is,
and I didn’t forget what the exterior
of the school looks like either.
Andy helps them ambush and defeat The Colonel,
but before he can get to the scout, Dr. Mixter
shows up with a gun and takes Chucky away. I’m
not quite sure how they let her do this. Yeah,
she has a gun, but there are 5 of
them, if she even tried to use the gun,
the rest of them could quickly pounce
on her. Then, she somehow beats up
Andy? She has a chance to shoot him right
here, but she doesn't, for some reason.
Episode 7 is called "Goin' to the Chapel". I
think it's referring to a lyric from the Dixie
Cups song, "Chapel of Love". This episode is
all about the exorcism of Scout Chucky to make
room for Chucky Prime to leave Nica's body.
We later find out this is kinda pointless,
because Dr. Mixter already has a backup
Chucky in her safe… I'll ignore that though,
because I have something else
I'd like to complain about.
(impact)
(suspenseful music)
The biggest obstacle that the characters have
to overcome in every installment is Chucky,
but there are also obstacles on a character level
in each movie. In Child’s Play, Andy is not taken
seriously because he’s a kid. In Curse, Nica
wants to get her family to see her as a person,
not see her for her disability. Season 2
is all about Jake and Devon wanting those
around them to accept their relationship.
They are trapped in a school and religion
that doesn’t accept them. They’re constantly
trying to invalidate that religion. So I just
find it weird that they successfully perform
an exorcism at the end, because doesn’t that
kind of say that the religion really does have
power? It’s not super shocking, because Voodoo
is a religion that gave Chucky power in the very
first movie, but it feels somewhat contradictory.
The deal to perform the exorcism is
struck when Kyle shows up with a gun,
leveling the playing field against Dr. Mixter.
– What did you do to your hair?
– I wasn't having any fun as a blonde.
– Because holding each other at gun
pointpoint is the perfect time to
strike up casual conversations about women’s hair.
At this point, everyone is brought
together to help perform the exorcism,
other than Tiffany, Jennifer and Glen,
who are still on their way. However,
Jennifer would not make it. After 18
years of being trapped inside this doll,
she seizes her opportunity to make a
run for it, and gets whacked by a truck.
This is a franchise callback. David, from
Bride of Chucky, suffers the exact same fate,
he’s hit by a truck while trying
to escape from Tiffany Valentine.
While preparations are made to perform the
exorcism, Chucky is tied up, leaving him to
verbally torture everyone, so Andy locks Chucky
into a bookshelf. This is a reference to the way
that Hannibal Lector was tied up in Silence of
the Lambs, and he even pulls out the same line.
– Closer!
– If you watched my Season 1 episode, you learned
about how Don Mancini’s time on the Hannibal TV
show may have been the reason that Chucky made the movie
to syndicated programming in the first place.
But the episode is primarily more of a
takeoff on another classic horror film.
– Your mother sucks ****s in hell.
– Yeah, we’ve all seen that movie too ***hole.
– The movie he is referring to is The Exorcist,
where the little girl Regan is possessed by the
demon Pazuzu to say the same line. Her possession
causes her to switch from the innocent girl to
the evil demon, hurling psychological attacks
at those tending to her. We see Scout Chucky
do the same thing, as he toggles between
“Good Chucky” and “Evil Chucky”. Chucky
also takes after Regan by projectile vomiting
a green substance and levitating up in the air,
just like in The Exorcist. The ending of The
Exorcist involves the possession being passed to
the priest, shortly before his death, and Chucky
follows suit with the implosion of Father Bryce.
Now all they have to do is transfer Chucky Prime’s
soul out of Nica’s body into the doll.
However, all the guns have been locked
up at this point. I don’t understand why
they don’t just tie up Dr. Mixter first,
then exorcize Chucky from Nica’s body -- but they
don’t think of that. THIS SHOW IS SO FRUSTRATING.
This mistake allows Sister Ruth to show up
and rescue the newly transferred Chucky,
but she’s stopped by Glenda, a knife
hidden away by Charles Lee Ray as kid.
– I need you to go get my old Bowie knife, I
stashed it in a loose stone behind the church
organ back in the day.
– No! No! Enough!
– The season finale is called Chucky Actually,
because it takes place on Christmas,
like the 2003 Christmas movie, Love Actually. We
see Dr. Mixter (now possessed by Chucky Prime),
goes into the safe at her office to retrieve the
spare Good Guy doll. The safe passcode is 110988,
or 11/09/88, the release date of the
original Child’s Play. Another easter egg
to the original is the maker of the safe:
Caputo Safe Co. This isn’t a real brand,
so it must be another reference to
Charles’ old accomplice Eddie Caputo.
The intro to this episode shows many of the
weapons that Chucky has used over the years,
including the snake adorned knife
seen in the original and in Curse,
the hammer used to knock Aunt Maggie
out the window in the original,
the red chainsaw that he would use later in
this episode, the generic kitchen knife which
has been used many times and the yardstick he
beat Ms. Kettlewell with in Child’s Play 2.
Lexy asks her mom if her orphaned
friends can stay for the holidays
while Mrs. Cross is live streaming.
She claims she was streaming to 100K
followers. Which is total BS. If I
go on Twitch or YouTube right now,
the top channels are maybe getting a quarter of
that. I guarantee no one is tuning in to watch a
small town mayor decorate her Christmas tree. On
Facebook, no less. And later, she claims this:
– My followers really seem to love my
nativity scene. It got over 30,000 likes.
– No. There are only 45K people in Hackensack. Come
on. And when she’s streaming that nativity scene,
the onscreen phone POV doesn’t match how she’s
moving around the phone. How do you screw that up?
Inside, Caroline and Belle (who
is secretly Chucky in disguise)
are watching the news about what happened
at the Lord Incarnate school. This calls
back to Child’s Play 1, where Andy and Chucky
watch the news for updates on Eddie Caputo.
I already talked about the defibrillator
used to take out the hospital security
guy being another potential Child’s Play
reference. Like the shock device in 1,
why would they even have a tool powerful enough to
light someone on fire in the hospital? And are we
just supposed to assume that there are no smoke
detectors in this hospital? Make it make sense.
The season long revisit to Seed of Chucky comes
full circle when Glen and Glenda transfer back
into the doll body from that movie, taking on
the new name, G/G. As another tribute to Seed,
G/G has a jacket patch that resembles
one of the Seed of Chucky posters.
One of the other patches is Tiffany's original tattoo.
But the business between Chucky and the trio
of Jake, Devon and Lexy is not finished yet. He
breaks into the house through the chimney, as
he has in Child’s Play and in Season 1. Also,
this season began with him escaping up
a chimney, and now he’s coming down one.
Tiffany Valentine can also be
found breaking into the house,
looking the Belle doll to transfer her own
soul into, but she’s caught by Mrs. Cross.
– Oh, my God. This is so random. And
I’m sorry to barge in on your house
on Christmas Eve...
– Oh, no worries.
– This is it? This is the
script we’re going with? … OK.
CHUCKY Season 2 ends with one
final similarity to Seed. Both
stories involve Chucky breaking into
somewhere he’s not supposed to be,
trying to get revenge on Tiffany and
getting a surprise attack from a kid.
Only this time, there’s another
twist on top of that. I mean,
it’s not a new twist. OMG Dr. Foley
was evil the whole time? Dr. Mixter
was evil the whole time? Caroline was evil the
whole time? Who could have seen this coming?
I realize that I was kind of negative
during this episode. I usually try to
give my analysis with more of a neutral tone.
But it’s just hard when the characters don’t
make smart choices. Like why did
Lexy leave the chainsaw downstairs,
when she knew Tiffany was still
upstairs? It’s just frustrating.
But I do have hope. At the beginning of this
video, discussed how Season 1 was an homage
to Child’s Play 2 and, disappointingly, Season 2
falls back into the ways of Seed of Chucky. But
what if that’s not necessarily the intention?
What if Season 1 is actually a tribute to the
entire Child’s Play arc: Child’s Play, Child’s
Play 2, and Child’s Play 3? That would mean Season
2 is actually a tribute to the Bride-Seed
arc. CHUCKY has been renewed for Season 3,
so maybe, just maybe, Season 3 will be
focused on the Curse-Cult arc -- bringing
back the horror, the suspense, and the
psychological manipulation of the 2010s.
Let me know what your thoughts are in the
comments. I’ll be here to cover Season 3
once it’s available, and I’ll be updating
my Chucky character timelines as well. So
make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, RING the deathbell for
all notifications, and I will see you in
the next one, assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)